قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان الروس
قصفوا مقاطعه تاخيرسون خلال ساعات الماضيه
نحو 80 مره وكانت سلطات الاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه خلصن قد قالت ان القصف الروسيه على
البنيه التحتيه والمناطق السكنيه تسبب
بانقطاعات كبيره في الكهرباء والمياه
والاتصالات
الاوكرانيا القوات الروسيه مستمره بقصفها
على سبع قطعات منها
للقوات الروسيه في مقاطعه
ودنيا
للقوات الروسيه قرب خطه تماس
في المقابل اعلن حاكم ومقاطعته دنيتك
الموالي لروسيا دينيس بوشيلين عن السيطره
على اكثر من 50 في المئه من الاراضي
المقاطعه
الروسيه ان وحداتها تواصل
عملياتها الهجوميه عند محاور دوناتس حيث
صدت هجوم مضاده للقوات الاوكرانيا
سقوط اكثر من 200 صاروخ وقذيفه اطلقت من
الجانب الاوكراني على مناطق في الدنيا
ومدينه دنيتك تركز على مباني سكنيه وسوق
انتجاريه اضافه الى احد مواقف الحافلات
العموميه الرئيسيه في المدينه
نتابع تطورات الميدانيه مع
مراسلين في خلصو تامر صمدي ودنيه سلام خضر
نبدا معك تامر
وهذا الجو المثلج الواضح
يتزامن ويترافق مع استمرار القصف وايضا
هجمات ضعنا في الصوره اكثر على الصعيد
العسكري
نعم حسن بالفعل البرد يشتد الثلج يهطل
والقذف يتواصل هنا في مقاطعه خيرسون وفي
العديد من القرى والبلدات الواقعه على خط
التماس نتواجد في احدى القرى بالفعل
الواقعه على خط التماس هذه القريه التي
يعني كانت على موعد مع قصف متواصل طيله
الفتره الماضيه طيله الايام الماضيه كما
تشاهدون العديد من
البيوت في هذه القريه تعرض لقصف عنيف مكثف
يستطيع الزميل المصور ايهاب ان يقرب لكم
الصوره بشكل اوضح لتروا كيف هذه البيوت
دمرت الى حد كبير العديد من السكان في هذه
القريه اغلى همم منازله
بسبب دعوات السلطات لضروره النزوح الى
مقاطعات وسط وغرب اوكرانيا الاقل تضررا
لكن كما تشاهدون هذه السيده ما زالت تصر
على البقاء في القريه رغم القصف المت رغم
القذف الكثيف هنالك سكان همم يرفضون
الاستجابه لدعوات السلطات رغم استمرار
القصف الكثيف القصف المتبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه تحديدا على طرفي ضفه
نهر دلبر في الحقيقه حسن القصف يوم امس
كان الاعنف منذ ايام رصدنا قصفا مكتفا
تحديدا بالمدفعيه الاوكرانيه التي كانت
تضرب مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه عند
الضفه الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر تقول بانها
تريد من القوات الروسيه ان تتراجع اكثر
فاكثر باتجاه نقاط مواجهه خلفيه تقول انها
تريد ان يعني ال- ال- العين مسوبه على
الضفه الاخرى من النهر والعديد من القرى
التي لا زالت تتمركز فيها القوات الروسيه
تقول هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه بانها تريد
السيطره بالفعل على تلك المنطقه بالكامل
وعلى عموم مقاطعه خيرسون خلال ساعات
الماضيه قالتها هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان نحو 80 من صاروخيا جرى على خيرسون وعلى
عديد المقاطعات الحديد في الجنوب والشرق
في ميكولايد منذ الصباح كان هنالك قصفا
مكتفا وفقا لقياده عمليات الجنوب الحديث
عن المناطق الساحليه عن منطقه اشتوكه في
تحديدا في
ميكولايف والحديث عن جرح ايضا التطور ايضا
متلاحق في زبروج يا خلال الساعات الماضيه
ساعات الصباح تحديدا قالت السلطات المحليه
الاوكرانيه هناك بان القوات الاوكرانيه
تواصل من قصفها لمدينه ميلتوبل لمدينه
تركماد هذه توك ماكو من التوفل هي مواقع
رئيسيه لتمركز القوات
الروسيه والحديث وانا اتحدث اليك الان حسن
يتجدد القصف من الجهه اليمنى في هذه
الاثناء القريه تقول همم السلطات
الاوكرانيه بانها تريد ان تسيطر على كامل
رغيف زبرج الجنوبي هذا يحتاج كثير من
الوقت كثير من الجهد كثير العناء وفقا
للمحللين العسكريين هناك لاكران تحديدا
لان قوات الروسيه تكثف من تواجدها في تلك
المنطقه لكن العين الاوكرانيه كما يقال
هنا مصوبه ايضا على ميليتوبل لانها تعتبر
خط امداد رئيسي للقوات المتواجده الروسيه
في المحطه محطه الطاقه النوويه في الشرق
نهايه ايضا الوضع لا يقل سخونه تحديدا في
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه في دونيت كلوجان وتقول السلطات
بانها الاوكرانيه بانها تصد تقدم القوات
الروسيه هناك تحديدا في محيط مدينه باخمود
التي تؤكد القوات الاوكرانيه انها ما زالت
سيطر عليها انتقل الى سلام خضر في الدنيا
سيطر على 50% من هذه المقاطعه همم ما الذي
يخص هذا ميدانيا يعني عمليا على الارض كيف
يبدو او تبدو هذه السيطره
مريم طبعا توسع القوات الروسيه والقوات
الحديثه لها كما تقول من مناطق سيطرتها في
مقاطعه دمياط تحديدا وتتحدث القوات
الروسيه عن هجمات احرزت خلالها تقدم جنوب
مدينه تدمياط بشكل خاص من دون ان تحدد
المناطق بالضبط التي وصلت اليها ومن دون
ان تقول ما اذا كانت قد تمكنت من الوصول
الى نقطه افديتك ام لا اهميه نقطه افديتك
التي نذكرها دوما خلال الايام الماضيه هي
انها النقطه الاقرب لمدينه دنيتك وهي
المعقل الاساسي
للانفصاليين المواليين لروسيا ان وصلت
اليها القوات الروسيه هذا يعني ان احياء
واسعه من المدينه باتت همم بمن انا على
القصف الاوكراني وتطيح ايضا للقوات
الروسيه التقدم اكثر باتجاه المناطق ما
بعد نقطه افديك التقدم الذي تم يوم امس
شكل المؤكد بحسب ما اعلنت عنه السلطات هنا
ايضا تم شمالدونيتك تحديدا في مريانكا
مريانكا هي ايضا احد المواقع القريبه من
شمال دمياط يقول تقول السلطات المحليه ان
اكثر من 70% من هذا الموقع بات تحت
السيطره الروسيه بشكل كامل هذا ايضا يتيح
للجانب الروسي تامين مناطق واسعه داخل
المدينه وفي القرى المحيطه الكره المحيطه
لمدينه دانيتس لا تزال تتعرض للقصف وهذا
ما رفع من اعداد القتلى في صفوف المدنيين
توفيت سيده في استهداف اوكراني لبلده
غارفكا السيده بقت بقيت عالقه لساعات تحت
الركام ولكن عندما وصلت اليها فرق الانقاذ
كانت في حاله مترديه جدا وتوفيت اثناء
نقلها الى احدى المستشفيات هذا على صعيد
الوضع هنا في دانيات استماريا القتال في
بخموت لا يزال مستمرا نحن عن معارك تدور
منذ اكثر من اسبوع معارك تدور بشكل مباشر
المدفعيه لم تعد تستخدم تقريبا في همم قرب
باخم الجنوب باخمو تحديدا القوات الروسيه
تحاول دفع القوات الاوكرانيه خارج المدينه
ولكن باخمت ما تزالوا في تحت سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه حتى هذه اللحظه مريم نشير
اخيرا الا ان وسائل الاعلام روسيه كانت
تحدثت في وقت متاخر من الليل امس عن وقوع
استهداف في مدينه ميلوتوكول ويبدو ان هذا
الاستهداف كان لاحد الجسور داخل المدينه
وهي طريق توصل او تربط ما بين ميليتو بول
وزابولوجيا وخيرسون ولكن استهداف هذا
الطريق لم يتم على عكس ما اعلن اولا همم
اولا قيل انه ربما استوديو صواريخ هايمرس
المعلومات المتوفره الان تقول ان عبوه
انفجرت عند احد اعمده هذا الجسر ما ادت
الى
تمه جزئيا جزيلا لك سلام خضر من دنيات
شكرا ايضا لتامر الصمادي كان معنا من